peter uh we are of course in st louis
the chess capital at the capital of
chestnut united states and 50 years ago
there was a match there was the world
championship match in reykjavik
uh
iceland that changed
everything history you can you could
argue everything but i think you should
take the lead there is a representative
of the winning side in that
in that competition allow me the honors
thank you so much yes everybody in 1972
bobby fischer challenged boris baskey in
what was a clash that just
riveted the entirety of not just the
chess world itself but the entire world
it was front page news around the world
and very much so here in the united
states i was a part of the generation
that got caught up swept up in a bobby
fischer mania and the world chess hall
of fame is featuring an exhibition that
has
tons of really really really cool
archive material and the exhibit is
simply marvelous peter yes i i took a
chance to
stroll a stroll across that hall and
take a look at some of the things uh
on display there it's a really really
interesting exhibition i probably will
return and because we were in a hurry at
the time and i would like to spend maybe
half an hour just
going going through everything in that
hole properly there you see a facsimile
of the
the chairs and tables
that
the match was featured upon again you
know front page news all kinds of
exhibits
photos uh
by
uh i wanted to say
the the name just escaped me for uh yes
harry benson a very very famous
photographer
recreating the scenes starting starting
from bobby's childhood and going all the
way to to the match in in 1972 and even
beyond with the
some before never seen materials so yeah
if you're if you're in st louis uh and
interested in chess history at all
yes you've got to go this is something
that is absolutely not to be missed it's
a tremendous tremendous exhibition